you're three things I care about money
cash and well I'm just chillin in my
movin now he by myself I got a girl
someone touching my
a couple things about myself I don't
like cardio
I don't like activity this is the exact
opposite of what I'm supposed to be
doing Hawaii I'm a punch Jonah's dick in
asleep but burns my chest hurts I don't
know why my chest hurts
Oh God I'm a booty see so far there are
two people that are prepared for this
how much I feel so many cameras watch
you three four five six listen take go
cronuts go the funny thing is maybe
Curtis super hungry right now look let's
just keep on going on incline
oh this price on the show because if we
get lost I need the calories in the
energy you guys it's Gloria blaming it
on me I'm smart I got someone shoot me
on my ass later oh look at the size of
that Dookie back now trying to get back
with the only thing that mattered is in
the past you're always playing games
hello welcome to fat free ducks Hawaiian
Vietnamese - I know everything about the
plant animal and tree this scientific
term leaf this scientific term but this
special thing is called tree to be
completely honest with you this look
just like the place I was born in a bush
I don't even know who my mother was she
just left me out here told me to live
and so I did that's why I don't complain
I'm going to feed him something come
here take this careful actually he's
gone he's going in all honesty if you're
going to do this hike make sure you are
not fat I'm not even sure if it's wet or
is it because of the mist but you all I
know is I look like a sausage here we
have the best view of the island as you
can see to the left of us it oh god damn
it okay uh-huh I forgot there is you
know we call this imagination hill you
can figure out whatever the hell you
want to see it mattered is in the past
I'm always playing now that I am back at
my homeland I'm going to move back I'm
going to build a house over here
maybe a nursery over here for my 14
children oh did I not tell you about
this plant called the bush oh yeah oh
[ __ ] I almost fell okay it's okay fun
that buck here to the front we have
found him one little Mexican boy selling
oranges on top of a mountain that is
crazy
not a hat here's a better question why
are none of you sweating we are sweating
nah I look like I paid huh your mustache
I see that ssam well the rainbows way
aha
drop-top we ride in California no stops
allowed we don't know yeah a sucks when
I rode the dosha favors a maple sweet
like the ocean is in motion
their presidents multiply like the
oceans cup looking half-full morning to
my bulges picking from the gut like the
[ __ ] is from the colon bowling XXX ohm
insects in the bone in like heaven the
boardies glory that are the butts act
like a mohawk and the luck ball deep
right in his story to meet the World War
II you will get to know me every tuba
like this time yeah I'll be doing like
that here do like this
yeah like and we do it like